[Music]
how do I make her stop she won't stop
play who are you talking about there are
two kinds of death wait I do feel like
we saw so many emotions from clay we
didn't really address his mental health
yeah head-on though no why do you think
that was I think that it's not fully
recognized by himself Reni the character
surrounding him yet and that's exactly
something that I would love to see
explored with clay and and whether it be
season three year I mean I don't know
how long the show's gonna go but like
just at some point in the future on the
show that's something that I would love
to address because even back in Episode
two of season one there is a scene where
his parents refer to these like these
meds that they wanted to go back on they
were for depression and isn't on it
anymore and and I think there's a lot of
um a lot of issues that clay has a beep
obvious to deal with and have to be
addressed and he really needs help I
mean season two if anything was proof of
that I think and that's it's like to
continue the conversation of mental
illness and everything I think can
really be explored through clay there's
nothing else I can do
[Music]
going to the very end of of the finale
then and you have Tyler and you have
clay standing outside of the school
tyler leaves and you have the gun where
do you think the story goes from there
I'd be surprised if the story isn't
immediate like immediately picks up
where it left off I feel like the 13
reasons why fashion is there's a time
jump and we just put together the pieces
of what happened in between I don't know
I'm not confirming but that's right I
feel like it's going I don't know what
clay knows that kind of how he gets out
of it
when we were filming it I did not
realize that the sirens would sound that
close you know how I've seen you in a
tie last year at the winter dance some
of the scenes that I loved were between
clay and Justin a new friendship that
was kind of formed yeah
how was that for you and what do you
love about that friendship what I think
is really cool is that the first person
that you see clay interact with in the
show is Justin they hate each other they
couldn't hate each other more what the
most unexpected things would be for clay
and Justin to become family and also you
know I think that Justin and clay both
saved each other in season two
I mean Justin's the one who talked clay
down from either killing Bryce or
killing himself and clay is the one who
went and got Justin off the street and
tried to clean him up and and and be
there for him although we saw it to
believe that Justin is still reverting
back to old habits but they needed each
other who would have thought that those
two people would be would end up needing
each other in order to I don't know like
even live right I'm excited to see I'm
sure they'll be like roommate still on
season three I think it'd be cool I'm
hoping for that but are we gonna see him
in recovery in season three do you think
I mean I hope so I mean I know do you
think that clay is in a place where he
could have another love interest in
season three I think if there is
potential I think clay would definitely
probably try to avoid it at this point I
think I imagine the last thing clay he's
gonna want right now given his
past record so far is is a lot of
interest but I think maybe he won't be
able to avoid it you know I will see you
and then before we wrap up here maybe
just two things that you would love to
see clay tackle in season three I'd be
surprised if the show didn't go into
exploring you know whatever issues clay
has but I think that there's a lot to be
addressed with clay I mean I think like
even seeing therapy at some point or
something just being having someone to
talk to and having clay be able to face
you know these problems that he has yeah
I mean I feel like you know if it was
season 2 clay was I'm really carrying
the weight of Hannah still obviously
more than before more than ever before
and other that's gone
I did see kind of clay being a little
wiser a little more grown-up given
everything that he's gone through and
just seeing how he deals with this
moving forward in his life and not
having not carrying the guilt and weight
of Hannah anymore
and and just seeing what new challenges
await for him even though aren't
involving Hannah because we know I think
if anyone expects clay to have an easy
path and any season we know we're wrong
I think that season three is definitely
not gonna be easy for clay or any of
these people if and if it was I don't
think we'd be I don't think they'd be
the show anymore
well and the writers now know what
you're capable of so I mean I man I'm
nervous to know what clays gonna go
through and see
[Music]
[Applause]